hold on your heads and watch your step
around the giant pit of dead bodies
because we have the scariest horror film
if you happen to have hay fever
Netflix's in the tall grass is a
mind-bending horror film from vincenzo
natali based off the novella by stephen
king and joe hill and in this video
we're going to be taking a deep dive
into its ending and shed some light on
the meaning of the Black Rock the church
the field the monsters in the time loop
itself so follow me into the grass
because here we go the ending of in the
tall grass is actually the beginning but
this time the time loop has been broken
whereas the beginning of the film sees
Becky and Cal head into the grass the N
sees them move away from it and that's
all because of Tobin who will find is
the key to breaking the loop later I
promise
but to fully understand the ending we
must first understand the beginning
since the film like the field is its own
loop we start outside the church and we
end there too this time however with the
characters having grown through their
journey the first time Becky and Cal
head into the grass were picking up
clues as to how the field operates
everything about it is distorted
directions sound and even time itself
when we later meet Travis Becky's
ex-boyfriend he tells Becky and Cal that
they've been gone for two months but for
them it's only been about a day if one
day in the field is two months in the
real world we can speculate this loop
has repeated at least 60 times since
Becky and cows initial venture into the
grass this is how Travis is able to see
Becky's decomposed body he is seeing a
previous loop version of her that wasn't
successful at getting out but before we
get too into the mysteries of the field
it's important to know why Becky and Cal
are driving through Kansas in the first
place although you may think Becky's
child is a subplot of the film it's
actually what propels the story forward
you see Becky used to be with Travis and
then she got pregnant which Travis
didn't light he left her and she decided
to give the child up for adoption to a
family in San Diego hence Becky and Cal
driving across the country it's only at
the end that Becky decides to keep the
baby and drive back home the tall grass
has given her redemption Travis arguably
has an even stronger character
he put himself in his career before
Becky and the child even encouraging
Becky via the a word I can't say it or
YouTube will de monetize me Travis was a
musician just like Ross but unlike Ross
didn't give up his career to focus on a
family as Ross says family's everything
there's one thing I know for certain
it's that simple truth but as Travis
goes on his own journey he sees the
error of his ways sacrificing himself so
that the girl he loves and his unborn
child can live he went from wanting to
rhymes with cohort his own child to
sacrificing himself to save it
talk about a pretty big arc but this
whole ending would never have taken
place if it weren't for Tobin he is the
only character that is successfully able
to break free from the tall grass in
order to stop the loop from continuing
about halfway through the movie we see
Tobin beckoned into the grass by Travis
but Travis went into the grass because
he saw Becky's car and Becky was
beckoned into the grass by Tobin this is
the loop it's kind of like asking what
came first the chicken or the egg
there's no logical explanation for who
entered the field first it's stuck in
this loop bound to forever repeat itself
the film however does give us some
interesting clues in Easter eggs for
example the novel Becky drops before she
heads into the field the same one Travis
picks up is Jane Eyre the story of a
young woman coming into adulthood who
has a child with a man she had a
tumultuous relationship with sound
familiar but to understand Travis's
sacrifice we must first take a look at
the Humboldt family and Ross's
fascination with the Black Rock the
Black Rock according to Ross predates
Native Americans
it's the geographic center of North
America and was carved even before the
glaciers carried the hills away Ross
even calls it the center of the center
on its surface are carved symbols like
this one with outstretched hands which
we'll see later and of the grass people
hoisting a pregnant woman the carvings
therefore or a prophecy of what's to
come the Black Rock also happens to be
the name of the church outside the tall
grass in fact it's called the Black Rock
of the Redeemer because every character
with perhaps the exception of
Tobin who does eventually get out has
something to redeem about themselves but
this church isn't here to worship God
it's here to worship the black rock
there are no Christian symbols in it no
pulpits just a solitary lock door at the
back the closest thing you do get to a
Christian symbol are these carvings of a
stained-glass here but even the tint of
it is green like the grass green also
symbolizing sickness at the back is a
solitary door which can only be opened
from the inside Tobin is able to open it
after he's transported there by Travis
after Travis touched the black rock he
was given its powers powers which
according to the rock can help find a
way out by touching the Black Rock
Travis was able to see the different
holes within the field we get a glimpse
of such a hole when Freddy the golden
retriever moves through this hole here
and winds up a cross from the church
it's these holes that Ross also used to
catch his victims he could always catch
them because he knew where to go while
they didn't but the black rock corrupts
as it did to Ross slowly taking control
of its victims Ross used to be a
Christian man so much so that he was in
a gospel band but the black rock
corrupted him turning his faith away
from God and toward the rock when Becky
has her child next to the Black Rock the
ground beneath it splits open revealing
hundreds of souls the black rock has
corrupted their hands reach upward
almost as if pleading for help
we know countless others have been
brought into the field just by looking
at the different errors of cars that
have collected dust in the church's
parking lot cars from the 50s 60s
present-day and all from different
states according to the license plates
when Ross attacks Cal we also see more
decomposed bodies laying in the field
who knows how many litter it's vast
expanse then there's also the question
of the green people that's what they're
called in the end credits
they are the force behind the black rock
and the people depicted on the carvings
they are different than the people
beneath the rock their faces are made of
grass and they themselves are corrupted
when Ross's eyes turned green here it's
an indicator that the green people are
acting through Ross via the black rock
they can control the grass bending it to
its will as well as move organic
material but once something is no longer
living they lose the ability to
roll it as Tobin says multiple times
throughout the film the green people
want flesh to fuel the grass and lure
more living things into its grasp the
decomposition of dead bodies helps
fertilize the land and if the green
people are to survive they need to feed
as Ross says later on in the film is
grass touching the black rock gives the
possessed person a window into the
fields many holes and branching paths
because it will help that person track
down more victims
it will help them see even when Ross
loses all of his eyesight he says eyes
are deceiving around here and better off
without it
director vincenzo natali focuses a lot
on eyes throughout the film here's one
of the opening shots of Becky another of
a dead crow and check out this shot when
Travis touches the black rock it looks
just like the veins coming out of an eye
eyes being deceiving is also manifested
in the scene where cow makes Becky eat
her own child notice how the edges of
the screen are blurred and how Cal
magically turns into Ross it calls them
to question whether what Becky is seeing
happened the way we think it did or
perhaps this did happen and what we're
seeing is just another unsuccessful loop
as Tobin says it's gonna keep going as
over in the final showdown
Ross tries to make his son touch the
black rock once again bringing up the
theme of redemption it's so easy son
Redemption it's so very very but didn't
we already see Tobin touched the rock
how is he already not corrupted we did
but this is a new loop another chance
for our characters to redeem themselves
in the nick of time Becky saves Tobin by
stabbing Ross with a Benny's Crab Shack
necklace were never given too much
information as to the significance of
this but its first scene when Travis
enters the grass and takes it from
Becky's decomposing corpse it seems that
this item has some sort of significance
to him perhaps it was a memento of a
time he and Becky spent together living
in New Hampshire I'm assuming that's
where they're from judging by Becky's
New Hampshire plates although it's never
mentioned in the film after Travis kills
Ross and touches the Black Rock
he's infused with the power of being
able to see the exit and quickly takes
off with Tobin before the corruption can
take over he gives him the necklace as
proof that he loves crabs I mean he's
telling the truth about the grass Becky
and Cal decide not to go in the grass
but Becky goes one step further deciding
to go the opposite way and drop off
Tobin at the police station in Topeka as
well as keeping her baby the events that
unfolded in the grass have somehow made
her change her mind with Tobin Becky and
Cal no longer going into the field the
loop has been closed but this doesn't
mean more people can be swayed into its
orbit we did see all those cars outside
the church so new loops will continually
spring up bringing its victims in an
endless cycle on the path to redemption
and a church or at least a building that
resembles one is such a fitting physical
representation of this the Christian
faith is all about finding redemption
through Christ absolving our sins
through the power of God the black rock
takes on this role offering redemption
in a different form one of the big flaws
of this film is Cal's redemptive arc I
felt like he didn't have one which makes
it doubly unsatisfying since his
character also gets out of the loop his
character really hasn't changed the film
sets up cows flaws being unable to let
go of his sister especially when it
comes to Travis this causes friction
between the two eventually culminating
in him throwing Travis from the
bowl-a-rama
for Cal to have a satisfying arc we'd
need to see him accept letting his
sister go but we never saw that instead
we see him pleading for her not to go
which ends up getting him killed
his flaw leads to his own death but he
is still rewarded at the end by getting
out of the loop something I would have
changed in the second act for his
character in order to make the ending
more of emotionally fulfilling overall I
enjoyed in the tall grass a lot more
than some of the derivative horrors that
have been lately coming out in theaters
it's a film that makes you think has
some gorgeous cinematography and didn't
feature any children of the
or I hope you enjoyed this video let me
know what you thought of the movie in
the comments below and please give it a
thumbs up and subscribe with the Belon
to get more thing story videos you can
also find me on twitter at think story
whitey and until next time remember
daddy loves you very much